please to introduce professor Guo
ping-pong the last speaker of this event
during the day he joined the McGovern
Institute in 2010 and holds the Poitras
professorship in brain and cognitive
sciences he's also the director of model
systems in neurobiology at the Stanley
Center for psychiatric research and an
institute member of the Broad Institute
he's played a pioneering role in our
understanding of the brain at multiple
levels including how neurons communicate
and he's really led the field and
continues to do so in developing models
of disorders including autism spectrum
disorders and schizophrenia his talk
title for lamech reticular nucleus
dysfunction in neurodevelopmental
disorders dr. Fung thank you I
understand I'm on your way to the
reception so I will be try to be quick
and first of all I want
thank really Pat and Laurie McGovern for
establishes of wonderful Institute I
couldn't find a better place to work
then truly but better place than the
margarines chip but that doesn't mean
you can feel me badly so I actually I
it's incredible I feel like both pattern
Laurie was in as we incredibly
supportive eyes the the best story is
when we want to start the mom cell
project we couldn't find any mom said
and Laurie went out of the way to we
found some in Japan but couldn't get
here so right when all way to have
breakfast lunch or dinner whatever takes
with his her you know friends who has
jets you know private jet ski ship the
the mom said from Japan and she found
someone actually supported paid all the
shipment from chatter playing from Japan
so now we have 250 mom said in this
building actually so this is incredible
so
I have the opposite of FEMA actually
when I you know when you say life is a
good time goes really fast I couldn't
believe every key for nine years I
started with only fear for like a couple
of years so pattern Rory is humble and
their family incredibly supportive I
never felt once they look over my
shoulder on the other hand Bob always
look over my shoulder have you made any
progress yet I'm seriously you come
every day asking how about a mom said
for Jackie do you make it work so I want
to clear that happened or they never do
that but the Bob does that all the time
you can ask so today I'm going to talk
about some project in the lab which is
still ongoing and you probably some of
you might okay okay so somehow you might
know my lab is interesting the cortical
strata that
thalamocortical circuits and especially
this dysfunction in new environments and
psychiatric disorders there are two
reasons I made a great introduction and
I mentioned many times that this is the
highly conserved as at least the parts
of a circuit is a highly conserved
between species and also she also
mentioned that the circuit is function
of the circuits have been implicated in
many neuropsychiatric disorders and the
neurological disorders and our
interesting is to understand both at a
molecular cellular and a circuit level
how this circuit function related to
behavior and how this dysfunction of
this circuits might contributed to some
of the symptoms are behavior problems in
neuro development and psychiatric
disorders and and today I'm gonna talk
about one particular aspect of these
circuits called a salami reticular
nucleus and this is a cabbage inhibit
inhibitory group of neurons which is
surrounded around the thalamus and they
provide a main source of incubation to
the thalamus and and that this is this
circuit actually
this paddle circuits which is a
psychological etim play a very important
role in controlling the output of thermo
output to the cortex so it has many of
different functions one of the main
thing it does is function like
gatekeeper because we receive old you
know sensory input all the time but we
don't react to them all otherwise would
go crazy immediately right so many of
the function of the TN is to filter out
all the information you don't want and
amplified what you really want so for
example in a party really noisy
then you have no problem you talk to
your friend and ignore everything else
right but so that's a very focus that
signal amplification however you're also
very flexible if it is a fire alarm
suddenly you will hear it and you will
run after so so these are the functions
that you end play a very important role
and play and also very prevent very
important in generating oversleeps be
node which is a very important for sleep
rhythm and normal sleep patterns and TN
dysfunctions being implicated in many
new psychiatric disorders including
autism and schizophrenia the reason we
are interested in this is that we found
not only you know theoretically this is
very important but we also found many of
the risk eating for psychiatric
disorders are also highly expressed the
in the TI n you can see this is a mouse
section of section you can see this
design these 2 genes are very top of the
list of risk she was risk genes for
force to free Nia these are the
monogenic called genes are called a
causative genes of autism spectrum
disorder and we actually started with
patch do you one today I'm going to talk
a little bit about patch do you want
because we use the passage where the
entry point to study the function and
dysfunction of the ein
the reason we choose that is patch do a
mutation extra is monotonic a cause of a
new dynamic disorder with autumn
spectrum features it has many other
problems and patchy one is we found that
earlier patch doing is actually very
highly expressed in the ti and I'm very
low expression other puddle brain and
later is still a highly expression ti
but other puzzling also expressed and
it's excellent Chris almost all the
pigeons are female or boys and the
pattern actually a patient has shown a
variety of symptoms including you know
interact with disabilities sleeping
disorder ADHD hypertonia and aggression
and also ASD autumn spectrum disorder
features and so so we saw this may be a
entry point for us to understand not
only China dysfunction but also how di
industry contributed to to some of these
symptoms the father impatient so this
this work was a very close collaboration
with my classes lab and in many aspect
from the beginning to the end so I'm on
technology and early this is mostly than
by one of my graduate student Mike wells
former graduates and and Ralph poster
and Mike's lab so when we made a
conditional knockout we deleted in
germline and we you know previously
collaboration with the Chris Moore and
my kalasa and my lab showed that is a
critical role in the generation of sleep
spindles so in the mice we found that
and actually Mike celebrity in vivo
recording the show that indeed in these
mice the bursting rate of this ti new
rasa reduced and lead to reduce the
sleeping spindles and these mice also
showed just what asleep and you can see
that and also the total time may be
different maybe a similar but the bouts
that the less of bouts of sleeping is
much shorter in an ahkam it means they
are wake up a lot more times and my
sleep is very different from humans we
don't sleep every few we don't wake up I
have a few minutes but am I to do so and
but you can see there's even more even
shorter sleeping pausing is nice now the
the bursting of the ti in neurons that
have been well studied they are
controlled by two type of channels wins
the t-type calcium channel a series 323
that is the sk ii calcium-activated
potassium channel and you can see that
previous TV show if you knock them out
either without that you will have
reduced the sleep spindles and
so we use slice physiology we showed
that indeed in this knockout mice the
the but Lube on the bursting is reduced
and however when you look at the channel
activities a current the calcium channel
current is not affected by the potassium
channel sk2 channel current is reduced I
said suggesting that the defect may come
from the defect of the SK 2 channels
since the XK 2 channels
calcium-activated and we look at the
whether there is a calcium defect in
these in these neurons and use calcium
imaging dye imaging we show that indeed
the the calcium concentration free chasm
country is reduced in this lack of ice
and suggesting there is a defect in the
calcium homeostasis in these neurons
maybe this is contributing to the SK
channel reduce the current in this
because SKT channel our chasm activated
potassium channel so since the ein has
been you know as I mentioned early China
has been implicated in the noise
filtering and attention Mike's lab
actually we use the mics a behavioral
master them approach Michael a developer
that
tests attention of these mice and
basically you this my scan which we
trained demise and to detect the cues
and in a normal condition and this my
son will do very well
both white type and knockout do very
well and then you can add a distractor
whether you distract the cue a
distractor and myself to remember this
is another the cue that get a reward and
you can see in the distraction in the
presence of the destructor the mutant
mice make a lot more more errors
suggesting that they have a problem to
filter out these noises
compared to the real signals now and
that suggesting the really you know lack
of cannot focus or just distinguished
between the cues and the noises and this
mice also showed hyperactivity and this
is the open field you can see the
in the whole 60 minute test they are
hyperactive and most of the conditions
are hyperactivity actually mice can be
treated with you know and amphetamines
which is a you know psychostimulant we
used to treat ADHD but this mice
actually are not effective you can see
that does not do anything suggesting
there may be a different mechanism in
this type of ADHD like a behavior in
these mice and so in addition to this
sleeping problem attention and the
hyperactive disease in mice I have a
whole bunch of other problems which it's
quite amazing to me that you can see
this in a mouse model for example it has
a learning disability whether you use
fear conditioning or using hippedy
avoidance test and you can see this
might actually the factory in you feel
learning and they might also very
aggressive they actually will whether in
the just handling them you can tell you
don't have the genotype that you put
your hand into the cage you know which
one is a knockout because it will come
by to you so so Mike actually microwaves
have to wear mittens to catch it as mice
and they might also have you know motor
problems except all these are fun
actually impatient except it does not
have the we called social behavioral
repetitive behavior we're seeing autism
spectrum disorders so so we are
interesting to see whether all these are
coming from scientists for me because
they are early on the TI is the major
side of expression of this of this gene
and the later on is expressing in many
other areas so we decided to try to make
a knockout only delicious gene in the TI
n now the that time there was no China
specific reso it may be really difficult
so we applaud we a you adaptive approach
used by by police lab actually a tackle
Spring Harbor basically this is a
Samaras telling Cree which is
somatostatin subgroup of inhibiting
neurons of overlapping with that with
the past even in the TR n but outside
adhere and actually it does not overlap
with the Apache doing expression so to
prove that we actually made an optimized
GFP knocking the passage even locks to
show that they do because if no good
anymore
and we show them besides grn there's no
significant overlapping of this this to
gene expression so that if we cross this
condition on our curve the wizard
somatostatin Cree then you can see in
knockout only in the TI n this is the
control UTI end but it's not in the
other boring areas this is near a story
perspective so with this now how do we
show that it is mice conditional
knockout CIN you will see attention
deficit hyperactivity and a sleeping
problem but if no problems in fear
learning in aggression or motor activity
suggesting that the TI n defect is only
responsible for the ADHD like a behavior
of sleeping problems and but not all
other end problems so we then tested it
is SK two-channel real defect is the
cause of this problem and luckily there
is a SK 2 is ASCII Chan or activator a
called a EBI 1 eb i/o so these are can
be used in mice but in low dose high
dose is actually very toxic
what we found is that if we use this
drug to IP injection to treat an M
animal and in a knockout after 30
minutes you can see that the high
hyperactivity is reduced and attention
deficit is a corrected but it does not
correct their learning that other
problems suggesting that it also you
know SK to channel defect may be
anywhere else but it correct SK channel
in the TR may be incorrect incorrect the
ein related phenotypes so the question
to us now is we got a really interested
is there a better target and SK 2
channel because SK 2 channel is also in
Hardy and many other places you actually
cannot use for as a target target is
this company is actually high dose is
toxic and also entry in these these
symptoms we see in patient including
ADHD attention deficit hyperactivity
steam from in many different SM you know
disorders and they are variable between
patient to happy and not everyone has
the same thing so how a TN can can
as such a small you know it seems the
uniform in the GABAergic a new roster
can show such complex the different
levels of behavior so we want to see
whether first of all whether there is a
subnetwork kind of the English I and
conclude different function of the
circuit and a second
are there more I could have targeted we
can identify two very specifically 40
iron can sure and maybe in the future we
can develop a better two of the argument
by the dragons to to alleviate this kind
of problems in your development
disorders so we decided to use a single
say RNA seek because we are here at MIT
and however these are the you know the
you know the inventors of this
technology is are all here so we
collaborate with several groups
including Unitarian foods group at the
Stanley Center Joshua Levine's group at
a Stannis abroad and Aviva's group al
ragù group at the Broad Institute
so we first of all we show that all
these neurons are actually GI in neurons
RK a pv positive and so almost ninety
eighty percent of them at least in you
might see a pv+ it to give us a way to
identify these neurons so we made we
have we made a pv pv tomato mouse so
allows to actually die set in on the
slides that i second that you out
because the TD tomato red in the
microscope for us a microscope you can
dissect them out then do a single say
RNA seek and we can identify of course
we know these occur but you can do runs
and we know these are pv+ GABAergic pv
so gather positive and pv+ new rather
are punitive TI n neurons so we want to
see whether these are subclasses
ourselves in the chair and that can help
us to discrete different functions of
these neurons and hopefully that
different connectivity what we found
that was actually surprising it was not
there are no clear clusters and
so it turned out to see there are two
opposite gradient a kind of expression
for each had hundreds of neurons up for
over 100 new a hundred genes actually
expression in a way that they're upset
one one group of a one profile one group
of cells you can see the expression may
are consistent with the wound of the
marker gene called SVP one the x
the most in this in this end and but a
much less expression in the other end
which is matched with another group of
genes markers called ECE are one that
they are grading expression the opposite
of this grade so you basically have two
great two group of cells that agree with
it with a gradient expression and a two
extreme of the exposure of this two
group you can see this can be marked by
SP p1 and there's no expression of ECL
one but on the other hand in extreme of
this group Grady until you see ecor1
expression but in no SPP wings so we use
this two genes as a market to to label
the extreme of this two gradient to see
what whether these molecular diversity a
focus and a functional diversity connect
the t-midi diversity maybe these two
cells looking tell us something about
the sub circuits of function and the
southern had awoke in the in the Tyrian
what we found it was a very interesting
that even anatomically the expression
they are location are very different so
this is a TI n and you can see we use a
it's very hard to see here we use a pv
for red and a purple you know purplish
for SP P 1 then EC au is green what you
can see is that the SPP win neurons
positive neurons are all in the middle
and the UCL wing neurons are edge so the
exact like share and a co kind of
structure even with this sinc T iron
structure and because these two group on
neurons they have very different profile
gene expression and many of genes can
show the excitability ion channels and
transporters so we thought maybe
electrophysiological there will be very
different indeed when we look at this we
used basically with the patch clamp
technology to record the
electrophysiology after we recording we
sucked the content of the doing single
say RNA seek to see what type of the
neuron disease and what we found with
you know we did a many many of the
recordings and in different regions are
of that you are an to make sure we we
collected the whole areas what we found
is that the SPP winner on they have
multiple bursting
and within a bursting they have much
higher frequency of interest in a
frequency and the other hand you see oh
you see you know you see yeah one you
say yeah
one neurons they have either single or
zero pass so they're very low posting
frequencies and within the bursting also
the the burst in frequency is much lower
so there are there are ribbon bursting
property which is the main feature of
the chain you know are very different
from this little group on you because
you see your one is on ads so most of
time if you don't know this you're
recording from you want to make sure you
poke at your lecture in the middle so
you don't miss it um so that's why most
of people when we talked about it before
is always this is rebound post in China
not actually is a group which on edge of
the and they are actually a very few
person and also we look at you know
facilitations
and the the SPP when you don't have
facilitation but you see here when
neurons seems don't have a very
significant facilitation so they are
suggesting they are pre synaptic input
may be also very different so these two
group on you're not only more accurately
defined it differently but they are
functionally at a cellular level they
are also very different and then we all
know that in the TI and in the thalamus
there are many different nuclei at least
you know generally working divided into
two type of ceramic do cry we need is
called first order which was really laid
out you know the peripheral sensory
input into the into the thalamus then go
to cortex the other is we called high
order which is basically connecting
between cortical cortical areas probably
their function is more more or less
regulated for example much of sensory
integrations or other cortical cortical
interactions and post of this groups arm
can you received here and input a
question whether they have how you know
are they do they have a differential
input from Bhatia and control a
different function because they are very
different functions from this
connectivity map so to test that we
actually use a retrograde be tracing by
injecting raspberry bees into either the
first order or high order new
ah thalamus then look at where they are
in the tea I am right this is this way
you can say okay whether then you can do
in situ and see others cells
PSV un+ are you CA you want positive
what we found it was very surprising
when we injecting to the first order
nuclei all the recipes go into the
middle and when you do Institute these
RSVP one positives and we feel injecting
to the high order and they all go to the
edge which is ie CEO and positive so
yeah I think that not only you know
molecular cellular they are different
they're connecting is also very
different and they have very distinct
can connectivity between the TRN and
difference different ceramic neurons so
we get a multiple sensory areas or from
each sensory area you have first order
and high order they are all same
they are very very same the majority of
high order received
you see your one a positive neuron
innovation front iron and a majority of
the the first order received the SP
human positive in innovation so so so in
the TI and also it's a very small thing
structure we have molecular query and
diversity in molecular I was in a former
molecular gradient and they have
different molecular you know electrical
properties they also have surprise they
also have a very different connectivity
so there give us the opportunity now
doing in vivo functional study to see
which of these 16 controller Hana
behavior and do they can show is the
attention or sensory filtering different
from the you know hyperactivity or other
sleeping dysfunctions and also allow us
to do Malec what are the molecular
Maxim's the cringe because we know every
single gene now express the most of
genes expressing themselves allows to
really study what are the molecular
materials are ensuring the firing
property or gabbana bursting properties
or other properties in these neurons so
and our hope is really use this
information to identify sub Network
specific molecular targeted allows to to
test and control or even module is a
different function and hopefully
in the future allows to develop
hopefully develop a some kind of
modulations may be applicable in the
future in the clinic and this also allow
us to now allows to develop a genetic
tools now we kick the rabbit genetic
tool very specifically to modulate the
individual 7ad works and for that
actually Sasha crow in the lab already
develop a somehow this is developing
user intersection method developer to
actually China specifically lines this
is you can see from edges so this is the
ECL one clear line this is in the middle
you can see this is the SPP wincleaner
so this will help us to really and now
we can start to manipulate this
different some data working in the TI
and look at how they can show Salamah
cortical output and a behavior so I'm
gonna stop here one all the older people
did this work as I mentioned parody one
is a collaboration between my lab and my
Colossus lab and Ti and I mentioned this
was mostly done by three very talented
people we want to post referrals when we
search site associated at abroad in
inches or is inching and Umbria lotta up
above collie the project both currently
a faculty job in cheese at actually here
and he is a professor at my university
and we a lotta just says establish
his/her own lab in Mexico City and and
the chain is a research associate in
Joshua Levine's lab and we have a lot of
help from many different groups
especially with with ten year and Joshua
and Aviv and my classes lab for this
giant sequence and many people in the
lab actually I am helped in this project
and I've also created grateful for all
the funding from the McGovern studio
Simon Center purchase center and the
tent and all other agencies thank you
[Applause]